whip reject nation we're back at it oh
my god leading up to spider-man no way
home we got a couple of things to do
today first things first a bunch of you
guys sent me over on twitter and
instagram this international tv spot
that supposedly features new footage
even some new scenes and the second
thing we gotta talk about is we saved
daredevil
so yes we gotta discuss this and uh this
won't be in this video but we heard
about the soundtrack leaks i might have
even listened to some of them soundtrack
leaks and that's going to be a separate
video that we'll put up later today you
know we got to spread some of this out
and you guys let's get into it we'll
kick off with the trailer and then we'll
talk about how kevin feige confirmed
daredevil
[Music]
with the fabric of reality
oh cool
what's happening starting to come
through and i can't stop him
wow
wow
i can't believe i'm in the saints i'm
saying it's horum
neither can i
i wanna watch it again oh watch it again
there's some good new glimpses here one
two and we tap from
with the fabric of reality
damn fight with a local levitation there
starting to come through and i can't
stop them
wow they're really showed and breaking
apart there
there's so much mirror dimension action
in this trailer and a lot of multiverse
breaking especially
showing that shot at the end i'm
surprised they even showed that they're
breaking through and i can't stop them
and they're showing that it's actually
from the finale like shattering apart
yeah what is coming through there at
that moment guys i mean yeah going
through this footage it seems like most
of it is an expansion on that fight
between doctor strange and spider-man
when spider-man has a disagreement about
the villain should be set free so
they're fighting over the cube i mean
right from the opening shot here
breaking through the mirror dimension
and then as you keep going uh there's a
new shot too yeah
like a [ __ ] video game character in
the background like the shot of venom of
spiderman
and then this shot right here i love
this one he's fighting with the cloak of
levitation the mirror dimensions are all
around here that's a sick ass shot
that's beautiful i can't wait the whole
sequence is going to be mind-bending
yeah it's pretty much an expansion on
this sequence here then of course this
shot is the one we were really talking
about afterwards okay this is from the
bridge fight obviously with doc ock but
then it's cutting into they're splicing
it together make it look like it's part
of the same fight but i believe this is
part of the doctor strange fight yeah it
seems like he's holding on to the train
or at the very minimum uh the cube that
seems like it would probably lead into
the yeah the train fight unless i mean
there's some kind of segway between the
freeway and the train but i don't feel
like geographically that would make the
most sense i love this flip shot
and then of course here more of the
mirror dimension of the fight on top of
the train i'm going to use this whole
city to stop you
confuse you so much that you dropped
that damn cube and of course the
entrance would net in doctor straight
yeah there was plenty of new footage in
here a lot of times it's just like a
second or two yeah this was like a third
of the trailer absolutely plus hey maybe
doctor strange is hinting there at the
end you know the whole thing about i
never thought i'd be in the sanctum
sanctorum me neither maybe that's
confirmation of an alternate strange
perhaps could be way to go john thank
you i appreciate that very much so all
right let's talk about this daredevil
news well i'm sure you've already heard
this was breaking the internet yesterday
it was all over the twitter my my
trending tab to say the least so i
already heard about it but if you guys
haven't heard here's a clip of kevin
feige talking about it himself if you
were to see daredevil in upcoming things
uh charlie cox yes would be the actor
playing uh playing playing daredevil
where we see that how we see that when
we see that
uh remains to be seen so just to
reiterate here's what he said if you
were to see daredevil in upcoming things
if you were to see him charlie cox yes
would be the actor playing daredevil
where we see that how we see that
when we see that remains to be seen so
here's the beautiful part about this did
he come out and say daredevil's for sure
returning even though we all know hell
even mr john campio was doing a stream
the other day and just flat out said
those photos were real i just directly
said it instead of trying to cover it we
know daredevil is going to be returning
but what the beautiful part about this
confirmation is is that they wanted to
preserve it to be charlie cox the entire
time when daredevil was canceled after
season three i remember just how bummed
i was because charlie cox's daredevil
portrayal is hands down i've said it
many many times he is my favorite
character out of the whole marvel
cinematic universe i know a lot of the
times that can upset some people just by
saying that but he's personally my
favorite portrayal i feel he's very
human and very realistic i love the
darkness the grit he really wears the
guilt throughout his whole performance
which is such a big part of daredevil
and i think charlie cox just nails the
role i love this because a lot of the
speculation of like will he be in it or
not after this weekend it's just been
completely thrown out the window it is
no longer speculation whatsoever charlie
cox is here to stay this is pretty
surprising as much as he stated this off
with the word if as he proceeds with
this statement
of say where how when it's surprising
that feige himself would actually put it
in the context like this it's almost as
if he's having fun with the fact with
just how many leaks there have already
been and it's like screw it i'll be a
little bit more direct with my feige way
of teasing things because normally he
would just answer something like this in
the way of going maybe he will maybe he
won't yeah
the rumors are true some of them are
false i don't know but he just said when
daredevil shows back up it's going to be
charlie cox you know that's such a
beautiful way to put it i love it
absolutely yeah yeah it maintains that
era of mystery but also gives us at
least a little bit of what we want and
two i mean in the grand economy of
things to confirm or deny i feel like
this is at least a nice one too i mean
nothing's gonna stop the tobii andrew
hype train but you know this will at
least put a dent in some of that people
be pretty i think excited and feel
pretty rewarded to hear them so now the
big question becomes who else from those
netflix shows is going to be able to
continue on in the marvel cinematic
universe absolutely and it'll be
everybody except danny rand probably
that's probably the way it's gonna go
which i wonder how they'll be able to
explain once that like announcement has
to happen because i don't know i mean
there aren't as many uh clues pointing
to the other people as you know to
jessica jones or to luke cage as there
are to matt murdock but there are
certain clues out there that's the big
question now i i mean it seems like
their priority would be to bring in
daredevil especially with all the
kingpin stuff so i kind of don't expect
to see the others for a little while and
i feel like they're getting to the point
where they're like so many cats are out
of the bag we gotta at least satisfy
maybe one of them so people will stop
digging so deep to spoil all this stuff
all right guys well what do you guys
think about daredevil officially coming
back i mean i know a lot of us already
believed it knew it from those photo
leaks just from all the speculation but
it sounds like they have actual plans
for daredevil now i'm wondering how the
events of this series will factor in
though to the overall picture of the
marvel cinematic universe are they going
to take those story lines directly like
involving the hand the two seasons that
really dealt with kingpin's criminal
organization like what are they going to
be taking from there or are they just
going to be doing they're from a
different universe but they're keeping
the same actors yeah you know i don't
know what it will be bottom line is it
seems like we're going to be preserving
some of the casting and that's what gets
me the most excited leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
sarah campbell wanted to shout you out
today because hey if there's somebody i
would love to see return to our little
universe start leaving some more
comments popping back up if we ever do
it live again would love to see your
face because i miss you and you've been
out there traveling the world doing all
sorts of stuff and i'm like what's sarah
up to is she out there doing good or is
she out there getting into trouble does
she need help does she need us to whip
in and rescue her with our senses i'm
combining characters now sarah this is
what you do to me i think of you and
just my brain goes to mush and i just
get this gauzy sort of you know soft lit
feeling and i'm like man
the world is a better place with sarah
campbell in it no matter which world
which universe which timeline we're on
always happy to know that you're out
there but hey just send us a line let us
know you're doing good
much love for now though hope you're
having a good holiday season
again you don't do that in real life